there are threads left dangling
prophecies unanswered and pretentious
warnings that now seem strange and
pointless were these questions
intentionally unanswered did the Game of
Thrones writers simply forget about them
or purposefully shunt them to the side
when the show took unexpected turns from
the White Walkers introduction in the
first episode to the moment Arya Stark
dispatched them all with a well-aimed
strike they were a terrifying mystery
here and there Game of Thrones dropped
tantalizing hints about the White
Walkers culture that we never saw
brought to any sort of coherent
conclusion we know that the children of
the forest created them from human men
and that they needed healthy human
babies to continue their line we know
that they took these babies to a place
in their home in the lands of always
winter which looked an awful lot like a
civilized settlement we heard them emit
what sounded like screeches but to them
seemed to be a sort of language
had they succeeded in tightening their
frigid grip upon the world they might
have had plans beyond mayhem and death
perhaps as in the books there were
female White Walkers hidden away up
north and a mysterious and unique brand
of ice magic unknown to any other race
early on in the show bran Stark was
soothed by the stories old nan told of
the children of the forest they were the
stuff of fantasy then magic myth and
monsters became very real indeed the
children it was revealed lived in the
far north
wielding magic in defense of the
three-eyed Raven after the walkers
attacked the children we'd met perished
in their efforts to protect bran and his
momentous future now their fate is one
big question mark where those children
we met the last to exist are there more
and can we really believe they'll be
content to keep their powerful magic to
themselves for eternity what does their
place and the balance of power mean for
the future their magic nearly brought
about the end of the world and their
creation of the White Walkers and they
are tied to the man who is now the king
of their continent who is one of only
two people along with mayor Reed to know
they exist at all it seems safe to
assume they won't stay silent forever in
the final shot of the series Jon Snow
marches into the woods ghost at his side
leading the wildlings home this is a
bittersweet ending men as punishment yet
also as something of a spiritual reward
John was always at home in the true
north unbound by Westerosi custom he'll
live on as I am the sword in the
darkness I am The Watcher on the walls I
am the shield that guards the realms of
men
but what does any of that mean the
finale surrounded John's fate with a lot
of pretentious talk but little of it
presented the audience with any concrete
plans will they rebuild the wall if
there aren't any White Walkers will he
become a new sort of King beyond the
wall will the new watch root out the
cruelty that flourished in isolation
like Craster's keep and the
cannibalistic fence all we know is that
John has returned to the Nights Watch
just as he began the series it's just
that now we have no clue what that means
religion runs wild in the world of Game
of Thrones
there's the faith of the seven most
Westeros follows there's the many-faced
God better known as death there is the
great stallion worshiped by the Dothraki
who they believe will mount the world in
the form of a favored follower and
there's the drowned God of the iron
Islanders who demands devotees ritually
drown so why does the Lord of Light seem
to matter more than the rest from
reanimating Jon Snow's dead body to
lighting the swords of thousands of
dough through key with a single chanted
prayer the followers of the enigmatic
fire God wielded actual power in a way
no other religion ever seemed to muster
some like the undying were able to
summon illusions through their mystic
practices while groups like the faceless
man could assume the forms of those they
killed but the Lord of Light proved
repeatedly that he could turn the tide
of history with enough sacrifice
devotion and Kings blood why did we only
ever see miracles performed in his name
after seeing incredible feats performed
by his followers while his religion
gained favour in Westeros Daenerys spent
multiple seasons in slavers Bay and
ended up mired in marine for three
seasons ruling roasting the powerful and
chopping the collars off the oppressed
turned out to be complicated word came
from youkai and a stupor that which she
had sent right had quickly gone wrong
again ultimately after compromise naval
warfare and the installment of ruling
councils and fighting pits
Daenerys left Daario naharis in charge
when she left for Westeros tasking him
with keeping the peace in the region she
renamed dragons Bay grey worm and his
compatriots are set to return to Essos
but are they going to do anything in the
cities they helped conquer has a leader
emerged from the native culture as
Daenerys hoped did the sons of the harpy
regroup the Greyjoy's promised to help
in exchange for an alliance against
Euron or any of their forces still there
for an area that took up such a chunk of
screen time the audience has been left
with startling way few answers as to its
fate the sparrows were a pretty big deal
for a while they were the only true
sustained threat commoners managed to
present over the course of the series
led by the high Sparrow
they were the dissatisfaction of the
public given flesh and voice so powerful
that they brought the Tyrells to their
knees and pushed Cersei into reviving
two faith militant forcing her into her
walk of penance she had to blow up the
Sept of Baelor with the high Sparrow
inside just
make them pause after that explosive
season finale however they were never
heard from again did they just stop this
seems unlikely as they were portrayed as
having a massive grassroots movement
supporting them one that seemed to
sprawl beyond the confines of King's
Landing their figure had perished in the
flames but did people really just accept
the loss of the soup kitchens the
sparrows ran did the faith militant so
fanatically devoted they carved a
seven-pointed star into their foreheads
truly shrug and lay down their arms
there is a new Prince of Dorne
apparently Varys mentions him in the
last of the Starks the new Prince of
Dorne
that is his support he later showed up
in Dornish yellow to vote for bran the
broken that's all we know about him so
we're basically left to wonder what on
earth has happened to Dorne
after oberyn's death his daughters the
sand snakes led by his grieving lover el
arias and led the country and rebellion
they murdered oberyn's brother Duran the
reigning prince of Dorne his son and
heir trystane and Myrcella Baratheon
both Cersei Lannister 'he's only
daughter and Tristan's betrothed this
brutal coup petered out almost
immediately
Nymeria Obara and tyene sand were all
killed and Ilario was left to die in
prison the royal family was wiped out
then those who wiped them out were wiped
out and then the first prince to emerge
pledged fealty to a queen who lost what
happens in Dorne has countrywide
implications and we've ended up having
absolutely no idea what they are Game of
Thrones characters married for
prophecies build religions out of them
and burned others at the stake to make
them turn their way the line between
organized faith heretical magic folk
belief and mainstream culture was
intentionally blurred
everyone from Melisandre to maester
aemon gave some level of credence to the
concept of the prince who was promised
Daenerys stole bone is the one who was
promised what isn't clear is how much
any of the prophecies mattered if at all
this might have been a purposeful choice
since Game of Thrones often subverted
expectations and fantasy clichés but the
sheer scope and story investment and the
concept of figures like azor Ahai and
others begs for more clarity did Aria
fulfill them though she wasn't quote
born amidst salt and smoke did
Melisandre wield of however she did
because she was part of the prophecy was
dead
eris on the way to carrying the prophecy
out until she went off the rails quaithe
was the mysterious lady in the metal
mask who offered Daenerys a bunch of
cryptic advice and Qarth we learned that
she was from the shadow lands and she
pointed Daenerys toward Pyat pree when
he stole her dragons she seemed to know
things no one else did and was seen
painting symbols on a sailor's back to
protect him from the doom surrounding
old Valyria she appears more often in
the books where she pops up to impart
truly opaque warnings but in the show
she never showed up again with her
unique costume and rarified knowledge
not to mention her importance in the
books she seemed to be the kind of
character we'd absolutely see again but
we never did and her strange words ended
up like the prophecies not seeming to
have much of a place in the final few
episodes where did her knowledge come
from why did she care so much about
Daenerys like the rest of Qarth she
receded into the background confined to
season two one of the most interesting
aspects of the game of Thrones world is
the bizarre seasons winters and summers
can last for years a fact elderly
characters used to chide young people
ignorant of the difficulties of winter
oh my sweet so much had what do you know
about fair how stark warns everyone that
winter is coming a signal of their
inevitable strength but also a reminder
that the summer can end at any time Ned
Stark remarked towards the beginning of
the series that their current summer had
been lasted for nine years and its end
was a big enough deal to end season six
with an episode titled the winds of
winter the biggest reason for the long
season seemed to be the White Walkers
who brought the storm as Jon Snow liked
to warn and indeed a sprig of grass
peeking through the northern snow in the
series finale seemed to signify that
their defeat meant the end of winter if
that's so why did the winners and
summers last so long in the centuries
before their return was at metaphorical
or literal or just bizarre for the sake
of it
george RR martin has gone on record as
saying there is a supernatural reason
for the seasons he will reveal in the
books but it didn't make its way into
the television series Prince Stark began
the series as a little boy who loved to
climb and ended as bran the broken first
of his name king of the Andals and the
first men in between he had the most
conventionally magical journey of any
major character much
made of his ability to work or see
through the eyes of people and animals
bending them to his will yet this power
faded in favor of his ability to
perceive all events past and present now
that he's king one wonders if working
even mattered he didn't use it to turn
the tide in battle he used it for
reconnaissance at most he didn't use it
to become King it didn't much matter at
all for all the time spent on it tyrion
makes much of brands underdog story but
he's also placed someone capable of
mind-control at the top of the Westerosi
hierarchy doesn't that give anyone pause
especially given how little brand cares
for everyday human concerns you don't
want it I don't really want anymore
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]